en medio de la crisis diplomática entre
occidente y belarús por la detención del
periodista opositor román protosevich el
presidente lukashenko defendió el desvío
del avión que permitió la detención
alegando una amenaza de bomba y que
desconocía que protege bitch viajaba en
el avión también acoso accidente de
estrangular a su país para organizarse
punto han pasado de organizar disturbios
a estrangular la búsqueda de nuevas
vulnerabilidades sigue en marcha y está
dirigida a nosotros contra nosotros
somos un campo de entrenamiento un lugar
de pruebas para ellos antes de marchar
hacia el este después de probar con
nosotros irán allí
a partir de los unos
belarús está recibiendo presión
internacional por parte de eeuu la otan
y la unión europea por lo que califican
como un secuestro la ue que está
considerando aumentar sus sanciones
contra la nación ex soviética quiere
aislar a belarús por vía aérea con
tensiones presentes a raíz de las
polémicas elecciones en 2020 que
consolidaron el poder de 26 años de
lukashenko y generaron protestas masivas
duramente reprimidas y el maltrato
opositores como la sur que murió en
la cárcel el lunes ahora rusia sigue
apoyando a su tradicional aliado aunque
asegura no estar implicada en el arresto
del bloguero
nos hemos dado cuenta de la forma en la
que nuestros socios occidentales en su
mayoría y de forma abrumadora los
líderes los jefes de estado y de
gobierno los representantes oficiales y
los medios de comunicaciones comentan
esta situación como si tuviera alguna
conexión con rusia
nick wass que se hará si en el nuevo
enfrentamiento entre belarús y occidente
la comunidad internacional exige al país
que respete los derechos humanos y ponga
en libertad a brota ceviche